we want to tell you about a startling
development in a case we have been
following
of a north carolina man sentenced to 80
years in prison for rape and burglary 64
year old ronnie long is his name
he has always said he was innocent and
he was suddenly released
late last week after the state of north
carolina admitted it could no longer
defend the case
and asked the court to vacate his
convictions
only on cbs this morning aaron moriarty
spoke to long
in his first tv sit down interview since
his release
[Music]
64 year old ronnie long left a north
carolina prison last thursday in
sartorial style
thanks to friends and family waiting
outside
who never lost faith in his innocence to
be able to
walk out them gays without being
supervised
love you man no doubt breath taken
when his lawyer duke university law
professor jamie lau
first called with the news long couldn't
quite believe it
he said jamie is is this real
am i really going home you serious okay
but nah
the state can't go back on their way
they got to stick to what they say
in fact the state kept its word finally
ending long's 44-year quest to clear his
name
it began in may of 1976 when long was
accused of breaking into a home in
concord north carolina
and raping a 54 year old white woman
sarah bost
although there was no physical evidence
tying long to the crime
he was convicted by an all-white jury
and given
an 80-year sentence i feel it though
the criminal justice system here in the
state failed me
it was only after spending nearly 30
years in prison that long learned that
concord police investigators
had tested more than a dozen pieces of
evidence and had hidden the results
that evidence as attorney lau described
in an interview last month
supported long's innocence did the
defense at trial know that there were 43
fingerprints found at the crime scene
that didn't match
ronnie long they did not did the defense
know that there had actually been a rape
kit taken
and evidence taken from the victim they
did not
did the defense know that a hair that
was found at the crime scene
did not match ronnie long they did not
but attorneys for the state argued that
none of this would have changed the
original verdict
and long remained in prison despite
growing protests and demands for his
release
justice delayed is justice denied
i'm 64. going on 65.
they took my life with me without 20
years i ain't got number memories
but yet still you say the evidence that
were collected in the case was
immaterial
until last week when the fourth circuit
u.s court of appeals finally ruled that
long's rights have been violated by
quote a troubling and striking pattern
of deliberate police suppression
of material evidence
the north carolina attorney general's
office decided to no longer fight the
case
and ask for long's release we were with
long
when he got more good news we just got
the dismissal from the
cabarrus county district attorney's
office you're clear
entirely that dismissal of all charges
officially gives long back his innocence
and his life he has a lot of catching up
to do
it's over mama i'm talking on the phone
and i'm thinking i gotta lean this way
here to be heard
look i'm thinking that's the only way
things gonna work long wants to spend
time with his family
including his wife ashley whom he
married in 2014
and visit the graves of his parents
i know my mother and my father died with
a broken heart
i'm going to tell them now when i go
visit the gravesite
your son is clear
the north carolina attorney general did
not want to comment publicly on this
case
so the next step for longer news
attorneys is to go to the governor roy
cooper
and ask for what is called a pardon of
innocence so that he can
apply to the state's wrongful conviction
fund
it's not going to make him whole but it
will certainly give him something to
live on
and tony believe it or not now ronnie
long
can vote and he told me he plans to
very good to hear and also very very
good to see an innocent man walk free
after all these years aaron thank you
very much he's very impressive ahead
what to watch
it is i'm always amazed always amazed
that people can lose
decades of their life and yet not lose
their optimism or their fellow feeling
all right aaron thank you very much